before getting into the arithmetic
details of the genome assembly
allows me to introduce a crazy yet
similar problem to the genome assembly
problem
it is the newspaper explosion problem
we have multiple copies of the same new
york times
newspaper we put them on a pile of
dynamite
and trigger the explosion
but please do not do it at home this is
just hypothetical
so the explosion tears
the newspaper in two pieces
some of these pieces got burnt
completely
some of these got burnt just partially
the question what did the newspaper
say well in order to reconstruct the
newspaper
from these remaining pieces
there's a very important intuition
behind
we use the overlapping information to
construct
the newspaper in this picture you see
there are two pieces and we can see that
they have
overlapping information so we merge
these two pieces
into one bigger piece and continue the
if you are lucky then you are going to
see the newspaper and the content of the
new york times
in june the 27th is
about the human genome dna
now i'm ready to describe the
genome sequencing and assembly in the
language
of newspaper explosion
similar to the newspaper explosion
problem when we have multiple
copies of the same newspaper here we
also have
multiple copies of the same genome
in this line you may count that we have
four
copies but in reality
we have millions of copies
also similar to the process the process
that
the explosion tears the newspaper in two
pieces
we also fragment the dna into smaller
fragments
these short fragments
are called reeds some greed
got disappeared and the task
is from these remaining pieces
reconstruct the original genome remember
there is no position information
is known so
a way to solve this puzzle is to apply
the same intuition
as you solve the newspaper explosion
puzzle
use the overlapping information
if you see two reads here they have
overlapping
fragment then you wouldn't
reconcile these stupid pieces into a
single piece
and move further
so this is the overall picture of the
genome sequencing
and assembly you have multiple copies of
the genome
the sequencing machine generate grids
and the task of the genome assembly
is to re from this street to reconstruct
the original genome
what makes genome sequencing so
difficult
the genome is like a book
written in the alphabet of nucleotide
atcg
but its length is 3 billion
but unlike we read a book a modern
sequencing machine
cannot read from the start to the end of
this book
but instead they can only shred the
genome
and generate short reads so some people
think that the general puzzle
is actually a giant puzzle but please
remember
this one is not similar to the normal
jigsaw puzzle
where pieces do not overlap
in the genome puzzle because read
overlap
so this should be called an
overlapping puzzle